non pas sont retrouvés samedi matin
m
thomas
je suis parti là-bas pour l'âge légal
je
petacchi non mais qu'est ce que c'est
david équilibre qui sont en train de
travailler collectivement
j'aime pas ce terme à ce que les gens
comprennent rien aujourd'hui la gaieté
match pour moi mais aujourd'hui qui se
passe vous avez un âge légal à 62 ans
il ne bougera pas loin vous avez un âge
pour les carrières longues et 300 ans
il ne bougera pas et ensuite vous avez
aujourd'hui attendez vous avez
aujourd'hui un système de décote qui
prenaient pas tous vos trimestre il ya
un âge dans notre loi actuelle un
francophone qui est 67 ans c'est à dire
si vous voulez annuler totalement votre
décote que ne déclarent pas tous leurs
trimestres et les jusqu'à 67 ans ya
aujourd'hui 20% des actifs qui vont
jusqu'à 67 ans qui sont souvent des
femmes et des carrières heurtées lancé
ce pour des cadres d'emplois et nancy
sont pas pratiques ce n'est pas vrai
gros sur de ses peines
non parce que les cars ouvriers maram en
dessus mais vous avez totalement raison
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on en
compte la pénibilité durable à ça mais
là où vous avez pardon et les chiffres
moi j'ai des regards des frais c'est pas
vrai j'ai bien selon moi mais cadreur
vise à bien des cas de 27 ans et cette
maladie avant de partir à 60 ans jusqu'à
vendredi
c'est
et les cadres c'est tout à fait vrai car
ce n'est pas la majorité de ses vols
jusqu'à 67 ans parce que souvent leur
quête et câble ils ont leurs trimestres
autour de 64 ans justement là l'air si
on prend pas les restes d'une cession
l'âge moyen du départ aujourd'hui il est
brave toutou de 63 aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les gens parlant d'âge légal
parce qu'ils veulent pas du cot mais qui
va tient aujourd'hui à une décote est
pénalisé par le système les gens qui ont
des carrières
c'est à dire des gens qui ont eu des
périodes de chômage non c'est fx mais
disent non c'est pas vrai assure une
raison simple c'est bien moi je te
bouges que vous le dire de manière très
précieux
aujourd'hui si vous avez moins de 150
heures de travail par semaine une vanité
pas droit à la retraite
demain ce sera pas le cas ça veut dire
que le temps partiel et les reprises
même momentanée des collines et
permettent de valider un prêt de valider
défend ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui donc le système change non
mais lol alors une pomme croire non mais
madame si vous êtes sur georges pourrait
poursuivre par contre je quitte un
million d'euros non un million de
signatures
l'été on en est on attend là c'est
derrick j ai dit maintenant à l'état ou
par non j'ai dit que j'étais et qu'on
fait favorable à un changement de la
constitution pour que ça rend la
constitution d'où viennent n'a pas
changé alors donc mais ne fait pas
attendre et s'évanouit quand même à
changer sinon c'est pas moi tout seul
qui peut la faire échanger
j'ai besoin de l'assemblée du sénat là
vous l'avez la santé 1 mais voulait
passer le journal as tu j'ai besoin
d'avoir la sensation avons passé du
temps additionnel et elle passerait ses
dossiers
je l'espère car les jeunes et on espère
que j'anime à l'opérateur nommé dans le
fonds espère impôts référendum chez les
messieurs le gouvernement pour la
réforme sans précédent pour les
démocraties soyons commander mon premier
la démocratie devedec effet la mention
citoyenne responsable avec des
parlementaires qui sont réduits folie
c'est la démocratie elle est quelque
part
maintenant c'est passé regardez vous
avez tout dans la rue mais ça fait du
monde jean bergé - pas qu'il y ait tant
de monde que ce dans la rue je suis
insensible
alors moi j'ai trop de travail
malheureusement pour pouvoir avoir du
travail que je fais séjour sur scène est
ce moi je faisais aussi et donc je suis
le par soit aussi c'est en colère se
disent aussi ne sont pas prêtes quand
vous dites légales etc
regardez la situation actuelle regard
dur qu'avec ce que j'essaie d'apporter
des réponses précises sur les sujets clé
je suis favorable
faire à ma place qu'on change la
constitution
mon père ne sait jamais ce jeu mais
s'avère défavorable au matelas de mousse
jamais
ça sera fort et son avis est partagé
comme il est dans le texte 2008 les
pompes et celle ci
[Musique]
c
le défunt qui sont dispensés non c'est
moi
on va faire la photo avec monsieur
peut-être pas d'accord avec cette leçon
bien
les 62 m
la misère
moi c'est différent et je me promène sa
part entière mais ça c'est simple je
suis je suis contrôleur de gestion dans
la finance explique heures s'agit il de
meslay du maine ou non construire et
donc savez quoi je suis embêté par des
balles arrêtées
mais vous savez pas laisser les gens
faire mais jules et julot soins vous
mais moi je donne mes coordonnées sans
problème l'évolution de cette offre
je suis pour le mariage mais si sérieux
mais si vous êtes étudiant l'armée des
policiers le mieux situé
mais ça va mal c'est bon mais moi je
suis quelqu'un
de conversion du sud en asie
on est tellement après on les gens se
battent sur des choses des fossés des
droits des défauts
go way et on se prend une heure dégagez
voir de temps d'accord qui se trouvaient
et moi vraiment je suis pour que les
choses se calment
j'espère aussi mais génère comme c'est
comment cécile à calmer les forces de
l'anp non mais c'est difficile mais si
les volcans sont extraordinaires la
gendarmerie la gendarmerie on arrive à
passer des journées à discuter avec les
faits ça se passe très bien
devant les honda parti fin du repas les
chants très tendu
et oui ma petite famille et les amis
tous les matches mais oui c'est ma
passion je respecte
elles ne représentent pas des
digressions
je suis un repenti
s'entendent ils vraiment
soixante cinq semaines c'est long mais
ça fout en sorte de m'envoyer un mail
madame merci madame